yes Nova I am here to fight the Empire
alongside you and you can help out too
by defeating the creatures we have five
days to recruit the most people to our
side
the rebel side that wasn't very clear
take my hand and together we can repel
this galaxy as father and many sons and
also thanks to Star Wars commander I
will be able to donate $10,000 to
child's play which helps kids who are in
hospitals play games and have toys and
use their imaginations and try to have
normal childhood because some kids are
stuck in hospitals pretty much their
whole lives or their whole child at
least so it's good to be able to give
them a little bit of joy there's another
part of the whole December deal that
I've been doing for charity and I'm
really glad that I'm gonna be able to do
it again even though I look really silly
so join my side the rebellion side all
the information is in the description
below
do not waste time we don't have much
time I will be letting you guys know
updates on this competition throughout
the five days that we have thank you all
so much for watching I don't know what
character I am anymore but I'm having a
bit of a character crisis if you
couldn't tell but to rebell without
aah-aah
thank you so much for watching bye bye